ん
こんにちははじめ社長です俺は以前ね
巨大ゴキブリを買ってねドッキリをしたんだけど
今回ねまぁヤフーショッピングでね5のつく日は滑稽ポイントが5倍で手に入るんでね
もうこのタイミングで買うしかないと思って買っちゃいました
いやーなんだと思います
やばいやばいやばいやばいでもやっぱりそうだったかなれたんだよです
うわぁ
フクロウから the そうよこれはやばいこれはやばいこれはやばいこれはやばい
動きが前買った巨大ゴキブリを6対
web ショッピングで買いました刺す時ねターゲットで仕掛けてみましょう
クリップ
ご存じ
最後に提案ですねはい出す
はいはいはいはい
えっ
別の大変とトイレ別かけます一応といれば掃除しております
これが俺のね
こういう
あとはターゲットを送るのは言いますだけど家に来たらすぐトイレに無理矢理体でさせ
ますではお楽しみに
me ん
ん
グーンって感じでねまあ巨大ゴキブリはね気持ち悪いと思うけれども
ドッキリにも使えるしコーヒー the 復旧ぶりのあの dr の復旧れが来たとき
にもこう
事前に準備しておけばこ対応ができれば完全おふざけ
お遊びグッズですがまぁこんなにが友達をビビらせたいときなればとてもいいと思い
ます
そこで今回ですねこちらのゴキブリ6匹を1名様にプレゼントします
1個6名様じゃなくて一人にブロックを上げます
やっぱりビッグな方がいいでしょ手でじゃぁ後急六臂をプレゼントしまーすちょっと一
匹一匹に僕のサインを書いておくのでこの子達よね
ぜひ当ててねよろしくお願いしますって感じでございます猫のヤフーショッピングさん
とのタイアップなんですけれども僕以外にもヒカキンさんとかササキアサヒさんとかあ
シェアさんと花壇
ってとかいろんな市場からのサイン入りグッズのプレゼントがもらえませ方法なんです
けども
ふうショッピングのアプリをダウンロードして下さった方から抽選で
u 2番のサイン入りアイテムがプレゼントされるという感じです
矢部ショッピングのアプリの画面電気があるんですよその応募するキャンペーンのその
ヤフーショッピングアプリが応募できて
ん
考えに
完全にねぼくだけちょっと浮いてるんですよ僕だけ猫の具9ぶり6匹だコースいけない
んですけど
やっぱりねインパクトなんですよインパクト
なんでねぜひね f ショッピングでショッピングする時マーコの月に買った方が絶対
いいです
t ポイントがつくんで頂上月放水だろいらないいらないとか言ってる君たちでこんな
のね
たう気皆無で手にする企画ないんだよてるでぜひ皆さんと応募お待ちしております
じゃん